244 on est direct touche
pas dans un instant on va revenir sur le
complément d'enquête et il y a de moi
qui sera là c'est l'invité qu' Fall
avoir aujourd'hui il est très colaire il
va nous en parler dans un instant on
pourra jamais pardonner à David et Laura
dans leur première interview Jade et Jo
àidé règle leur compte regardez petit
rcap et Miriam Palomba sera avec nous
dans un instant
regardez ce weekend de TF1 diffusera une
interview exclusive de Jade et Joy les
filles de Johnny HID elles raconteront
leur vie à Los Angeles et évoqueront la
mémoire de leur père et alors que David
hidday avait récemment émis le souhait
de renouer avec elle sont jamais
responsable c'est des jeunes femmes
aujourd'hui le magazine Paris Match
publie leur première interview choc
avant celle de 7 à 8 dans laquelle jade
Joy aujourd'hui âgé de 19 et 15 ans ce
livre sur leur vie à Los Angeles sur
leur mère mais aussi sur la bataille
juridique autour de l'héritage et cible
David et Laura ils nous ont blessé je
n'oublierai jamais ce qu'ils nous ont
fait alors jade Joy ALID des règle leur
compte dans leur premier prre
interviewiam Palomba nous explique tout
ce soir dans
TPMP bonsoiriam merci d'être
là alors Jade et Jo pourquoi elle donne
des interviews dans la presse et ben là
elles sont en pleine promo comme je vous
l'ai déjà dit pour le 7 à 8 il y a
l'exposition le 22 décembre à Versailles
sur le enfin l'exposition de versaill
sur sur la vie de Johnny où on va voir
où il vivait ses costumes et cetera
enfin une très grande rétrospective et
du coup aujourd'u là elles sont en
pleine promo de cet événement pour pour
le promouvoir en France alors qu'il a
été déjà fait en Belgique alors euh en
ce moment
elles ont dit des trucs de fou euh ouais
alors elle a dit elles ont dit par
exemple que alors elles ont parlé de
leur relation avec leur père alor c'est
c'est c'est assez elles ont dit plein
plein de choses elles nous parlent de
leur vie à Los Angeles ell nous parlent
de leur père elle nous parle de de de de
comment s'appelle que leur père était
donc un homme généreux que leurs parents
sont formidables que latia était
également une une mère parfaite et puis
elles nous disent des choses comme ça
qui sont un peu un peu fortes comme
comme le fait que Joy a gardé la
couverture avec
laquelle Johnny est parti elle dort avec
elle continue à se perfumer elle nous
explique aussi que avec Johnny il était
c'était un papa cool qui qui leur
faisait voir des des films d'horreur
alors que que Laeticia est plutôt une
maman sévère elle leur a même donné des
fessés parce qu'elle le vérité je je
rappelle juste que ça c'est puni ça par
la loi mais bon peu importe et donc elle
nous donne plein de petits détails sur
sur leur leur vie de famille et puis
tout d'un coup bam elle balance
sévèrement avec des mots très très durs
sur David et Laura ouais elle dit Laura
essayé un temps alors jade elle dit
Laura essayé un temps de tenir son rôle
de grande sœur elle faisait comme si on
était super proche mais en réalité j'ai
tout roujour eu le sentiment qu'il y
avait entre nous une barrière petite je
m'accrochais à l'idée que j'avais un
grand frère et une grande sœur parce que
je trouvais ça bien à présent il ne me
manque même plus et je dit cela fait 6
ans que l'on ne sait pas parler on a
l'impression d'être des étrangères pour
eux euh elle raconte qu'après la mort de
leur père de nombreuses personnes à leur
proches de la famille leur ont tourné le
dos beaucoup et surtout pour certains
des gens qu'on voyait presque tous les
jours avec lesquels on partait en
vacances du jour au lendemain après que
papa soit parti il n'ont plus donné de
nouvelles parties effacé euh oui parle
même de leurs de leurs anciens parins
Jean-Claude d'ond et Luana Belmondo qui
le calcu même c'est pas vrai hein je bah
il dit peut-être c'est pas vrai mais en
tout cas elle c'est ce qu'elles disent
que elles ont d'ailleurs choisi d'autres
parins maximci et Len darose pour Joy et
Jade AG Jean Renault et Marie ponanovski
qui sont des amis de longue NAT dira sa
vérité j'espère par SMS bah j'espère
aussi mais oui elles sont elles sont
très très dures parce que déjà elles les
trait de menteur hein elles disent que
c'est une trahison qui a eu un abandon
queils leur avaient fait que que Laura
et David leur avaient fait énormément de
promesses notamment lors de
l'enterrement à Saint-Bart et puis au
final rien n'a été tenu ils n'ont pas
gardé du tout contact ça va faire
extrêmement plaisir dire à David
notamment qui qui leur a tendu la main
récemment en leur disant que sa porte
était grande ouverte
quand on quand on lit entre les ligne on
a quand même le sentiment qu'elles ne
veulent plus entendre parler ni de David
ni de Laura d'accord alors elle parle
aussi elle raconte à quel point jade
raconte à quel point elle a été jalouse
de l'arrivée de Joy dans la famille
ouais ouais ouais qu'elle a même poussé
dans les escaliers c'est c'est voilà
tellement elle était jalouse qu'elle lui
volé à manger que bon maintenant
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est derrière elle
elles ont une une relation très
fusionnelle
elles vivent même presque comme des
jumelles ell s'échangent les t-shirts
elles dorment ensemble jade va la
chercher à l'école enfin voilà elles
sont très très très très complices et
Johnny voulait adopter un troisième
enfant elles ont refusé oui ell on
refusé elles le disent aussi alors elles
disent aussi qu'elle voit des signes que
leur enverrait leur père de là où je dit
moi j'ai l'impression par moment qu'
nous envoie des signes et ça m'apèse il
y a un an Jad des moi devionion quitter
Marne pour rentrer suivre nos cours à
Los Angeles j'avais envie de pleurer
comme chaque fois que je quitte cette
maison mais à peine monter dans la
voiture la première chanson qui a j'ie
de ma playlist c'était papa euh oui
c'est ça elle raconte donc elles ont des
fois des signes elles entendent leur
père à la radio elle raconte aussi que
après l'enterrement de saintbart elle
allume la radio et elle entend une
chanson de Johnny elles expliquent aussi
que elles ont une plélu chacune avec
leurs titres préféré de leur père que
qu'elles sont toujours très très très
connecté qu'ils étaient il y avait un
vrai lien entre eux d'ailleurs c'est ce
que disait Johnny hein que il était
vraiment très lié à ses filles bien plus
qu'il ne l'a étit avec Laura et David
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il y a eu
des tensions entre entre tout le monde
alors elle dit aussi je me demande ce
qu'il aurait pensé ou dit ce qu'il
aurait voulu dans ma chambre j'ai gardé
cette vieille guitare qui l'emportéit
partout et la couverture dans laquelle
il est parti je dors je dors avec elle
et parfois je je vaporise dessus son
parfum Caron un homme de Caron ah ouais
oui c'est ce que mait Johnny non mais
c'est c'est il faut pas oublier quand
même c'était des c'était des enfants
cétait gamines ce sont des gamines elles
avaient 13 ans et 9 ans lors de
l'enterrement sûrement qu'elles ont
entendu plein de choses à la maison et
que donc du coup elle réagisse comme ça
maintenant donc céit un peu non mais ce
qui en plus ce la partie aussi qui est
forte dans l'interview c'est quand elles
prennent la défense de le de leur mère
en disant que David et Laura sont des
menteurs et que jamais leur mère les a
empêché empêché David et Laura de voir
leur père avant qu'il Meur donc ça il
disent carrément c'est des gros
mensonges c'est pas envisageable que ça
que ça soit dicté par par alors ça peut
être effectivement dicté par latia faut
savoir que cette interview a été
réalisée en même temps que celui de 7 à8
par audreé crespoara elles sont c'était
le 18 novembre ell elles sont allées en
même temps et que effectivement audreé
Crespo et même la directrice de la
rédaction de de de Paris Match qui a
fait cette interview dit que à aucun
moment laéticia était présente donc oui
mais ça serait par avant je trouve que
pour des jeunes filles de 15 ans et 19
ans elle s'exprime quand même alors
c'est vrai qu'elle s'exprime super bien
là dans Paris Match ça a été forcément
énormément relu c'est des des interviews
une interview qui a été négociée et
cetera mais quand même elle balance pas
mal on verrare un peu autre chose dans C
à8 parce que elles vont évidemment pas
s'exprimer de la même façon que dans
Paris Match oui qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur le parfum ouis le parfum je suis
content dit c'était une
vraieo homme de grosse inf de Bernard
Monti c'est marqué dans l'interview
plus c'est pour ça c'est ce que raconte
notre ami elles ont parlé de l'héritage
oui alors elles comprennent pas pourquoi
alors qu'il porte le même nom enfin
normalement quand on est dans une
famille normale on porte le même nom se
soutient on n'attaque pas sa famille en
justice donc ça elles ne l'ont pas
compris et en même temps bon c'est un
peu délicat parce que elles elles ont
tout et David elura n'avait rien parce
que j'imagine quand Laura et David
lisent l'interview où ils découvrent que
elles ont la guitare les boucles
d'oreilles le collier enfin qu'elles ont
plein d'objets de leur père et que eux
n'ont strictement rien nu je peux
comprendre qu'il est quand même des
tensions et que de la rancœur de la part
de David et Laura alors elles évoquent
aussi le deuil que traverse leur mère à
létia depuis 6 ans jade elle dit je
crois que papa lui manquera toujours
même si elle va mieux maintenant oui
c'est ça elle dit que leur mère va mieux
que elle parle beaucoup avec elle bah
Laeticia est partie se recueillir sur la
tombe de Johnny à Saint-Bart comme comme
tous les ans là récemment et que
effectivement de toute façon chez
Laeticia la maison est quand même encore
vachement imprégné de de Johnny he il y
a énormément d'objets il y a énormément
de photos donc même si Laeticia a des
relations euh amoureuse avec d'autres
hommes forcément la l'ombre de Johnny
plane toujours sur la maison ouais voilà
bah merci en tout cas c'est l'info ce
sera donc lundi hein on reviendra dessus
bien sûr
lundi euh